hello and welcome to this video this is
around five of the London chess classic
as I was told it's not the classics for
some reason it's a chess classic okay um
let's get going for round five starting
with aronian against Carlton and we got
Noble in defense that's good so our own
en goes for one c4 as he does quite
frequently these days and carlton goes
for this defense the symmetrical with an
early night to have six and what he is
after it seems is um gap the Hedgehog
like it could happen after after these
moves this is something that Carlton has
played over the years quite often but
aronian decides to go III something
entirely different yeah g3 is a more
principled move but III is a pretty
decent way to get something something
different than they had shock yeah
cousin goes for quick d5 very logical
striking in the centre takes 90 x and d
for ya if black would have taken with
the pawn we would have gotten an
isolated queen palm position that
definitely is ok for black but carless
after something else 95 yeah no wrong
yet goes default and here it is white
who gets an isolated creep on it's quite
interesting how move orders and
transpositions work and chess this
position is most of the time reached via
something entirely different that's so
just go back for a moment yes that's a
current panel and okay yeah well we
would really we need to do it like that
to get the exactly the same position
yeah so it can happen
from completely different Wars this is
the same position yeah here normal move
that would be Bishop e7 knight c6 or
Bishop before one of those but cousin um
has a surprise in store traded on c3 and
played Queen to d7 yeah it's quite
remarkable he has a real boat load of
slightly obscure lines web skewers wrong
I mean it's not a bad line it's just
that it's virtually unknown and it is
completely playable of those kind of
lines in store i had to get fresh
positions in games and avoid specific
preparation ok this is hanging and
Aronian gets to cover it 97 looking to
cover you five should be three and now
be six yeah black wants to play Bishop
to be seven possibly be sure d 6 and
then castle yeah interesting move now by
a Roman he goes Knight g5 I think that's
a good idea trying to get some kind of
initiative out of that if Black gets
simply to develop Bishop d7 and bit
should be six I think he has equalized
already and here it gets more
interesting why does simply threatening
that pawn and in some cases to get the
Queen out yeah so Knight f6 was played
covering age 7 and bringing the night
over so that there is no Queen coming to
those some squares queen of three now or
ever interesting move Bishop d7 is no no
good due to that check and the King has
to move we just say yeah something that
black definitely wants to avoid you
something like that check is to be
avoided rugby 8 has to be played yeah so
it's way better here hmm it seems that
he's he's got better development but it
seems that black is completely okay
because he gains 10 p by the next moves
castles bishop d6
this is a temple on the pond and why it
has to do something about it he goes
queen age three that makes lots of sense
not playing something like 83 which
would be really lame this is better
looking at that pawn Iran on age 7 and
preventing canceling for the moment yeah
Carter played age six preparing to
castle and now it's a it's important
moment here in this game what should
aronia do it seems that after the game
is said that he could have gone f4 in
this position and this is a lot sharper
that's definitely true I mean black is
not attacking this age six is mostly a
prep move for castling yeah he could
have played their forward I'm absolutely
unsure this is yeah that brilliant I
mean if black just castles is that so
bad I mean white has to go back now to
you for jf three and in both cases I
don't see anything terrible happening to
black let's see you goes here this is e
five that's all right bad so he has to
go to you actually yeah now like and say
trades and place and i'll push your
basics something like that i don't think
that is so bad for black he's got very
decent counter chances and note that
there is also the idea that black is
simply pushing this you have to be you
have to be em again without prejudices
about the e6 porneia that pawn looks bad
but this Bishop also looks bad and with
f5 it's the end of all kind of attacking
ideas and if Black gets in this for
example he is perfectly fine so I think
our foremost was more aggressive maybe
but if it's better unsure it's clear
whatever that this is how it was played
and after Bishop f4 cards and has no
problems whatsoever why Bishop f4
because Bishop takes h6 is something
that can be troublesome
trade the bishops here and this is what
happened Black has accomplished two
things he avoided any sacrifice on age
six and the second effect is that now
this night has gained enormous stability
it cannot now I cannot be disturbed
anymore by a bishop coming to if I for
example that it might threaten the to
take the night and to damage the porn
structure on f6 that night is just
sitting there like a rock and protects
important important squares it's an
important device trading bishops
sometimes to ensure that your Knights
have more stability for example that
night it's not very stable as it can
always be attacked by the bishop and we
came in here white has no problem with
putting it only five but it's just that
f3 is not a very stable square for that
piece yeah i think that here black
shouldn't have any problems and after
the Queen trade pin it became clear that
there is not that much that both sides
can hope for White has the hanging pawns
and if the position Lex dynamism um
dynamics dynamism yeah if it lacks
dynamic play then often the pawns are
more weakness and strength he however he
has easy ways to to cover them and
interested equal position everything
else would be yeah exec waiting on false
information is just equal yeah aronian
tried with d5 breaking through but black
is immensely solid check no no got into
trading down to rook endgame and after
okay five we see huh painting wrong that
there is a pawn to worry about it here
they agreed to a draw it was a very
sound a solid game by both sides yeah
it's sometimes not so easy to say what
what about this kind of
it's not very exciting but what what
happened here um I mean okay III is an
interesting sideline and can it can lead
to a sharp play in the isolated queen
porn positions so um aronian it's not
yeah to be blamed or so for that
decision but if we look at this for
example white can also play something
like this where he goes with efore and
d4 and it goes for some kind of attack
and it's a bit tame how this was played
maybe on the white side okay so let's go
to the next game Adams Nakamura and yes
it what can be too it's it's that
dreaded opening again I'm not quite sure
I mean I think probably half of the
overall games of that event was possible
in defense and yeah I don't I don't
quite understand why white players still
go for it but anyway well in Adams case
it's a it's a saying I mean he's a
lifelong 1t four player auntie debbie
reality has played anything else so it's
a bit difficult for him to do something
else but for many others I'm not quite
sure why they keep playing into the
balloon okay anyway we have d3 now
should see five ticks ticks ninety to
ninety seven nights before we've seen
something similar many times um again I
can tell you that why I cannot take the
porn yeah double checking so Bishop t2
rookie 8 f 69 f 8 yeah so here's
something is some that should be it
should be said what is black doing here
one idea that black sometimes has is
that he tries to put the night of one of
those squares and he also of course had
to free the bishop that bishop on c8 and
this is Nakamura choice I think black
has a very again sound solid position
and the White has little to play form I
don't really quite see what white
players see in this kind of thing
because this is nothing going on yeah so
when age six was played g6 and now
Castle she had an interesting way of
playing first push the H point of the
morn and then castles I was pretty
surprised when I saw that because well I
couldn't really see how that age pawn
push relates to white cancelling short
um one thing though black is immediately
now trying to go for that pawn it's
funny he definitely managed to get it
yeah night 94 getting to the Queen trade
and now after this that porn was in the
way isolated from what white zombie this
should be three and back and then it's
gone yet what could not keep it if he
goes here I reckon that you maybe could
have tried but ok black can still go
here and pick it up with Bishop f8 to h6
the thing is in the game man white also
lost their porn but if you look at this
position this is the worst bishop Evan
almost not the worst ever but it's
pretty bad and white has excellent
control over the squares f5 and age 5
plus we have we have the queenside
situation where with that porn you know
that black is never going to get a
person in any any kind of form
yeah those two squares this is a very
solid locating position yeah why
shouldn't blunder stuff samples so he
went f4 I think white as white simply
has full compensation for the porn I
mean it's not a compensation like an
attacking compensation but white is
definitely i'm active enough and placed
well enough to easily [ __ ] would ya
like it never gets to can kind of from
state way you can think about converting
the porn it just doesn't happen um also
sometimes if we look at the position
it's it's useful to think about it in
terms um what exactly is the extra part
i mean here PA blacks extra porn is
arguably c7 and this is not very useful
in this position I mean if we would have
this position without that porn I mean
just imagine it without the pawn then we
would rather be white in this position I
think yeah because h6 is a little bit
weak d for is a little bit weak and so
on and there's simply no reason
whatsoever for black to hope for
something of course he tried yeah that
sets a very clearing we have someone
moves but there is no one no headway and
to be mayhem and I got this in Weiss
walks get active and well there are
still those those plenty porn weaknesses
check yeah this was the next stage of
this game but this is lost em this is a
lost porn
and why it was getting into the king at
porn and came rather quickly yeah well
here what what is there this is a
singing and so what is black supposed to
do something like this he might even
blue lose that game in check this is
coming up to be five black cannot win
this it's a it's a bit strange that
concept out of the opening I think to
push the H pawn up the board and then to
Castle shorten but maybe white is
shooting for something like moving that
night and playing for some kind of f4f
six has been weakened but ok this is a
very sound approach here we get to the
end game and I think it's just very very
dry and at the end it was a draw okay so
let's go for the next game and yeah the
Berlin quotes quote is very high got it
again ok this is this time we have a
line like that and the GU show goes
Bishop is six yeah this is probably
played to prevent night see form early
night c4 it doesn't change much in terms
of the structure it's still a fairly
yeah sound solid slightly boring
structure and d4 now by kawana that's
interesting he opens up the position now
um yeah because of that idea black
cannot take and goes 97 the interesting
moment is a little bit later here we
have this change to a pawn structure
that is well known from the ruler PES
exchange Black has got the two bishops
as compensation for that slightly
devalued pawn structure is this four
against three and four against three are
not that valuable it's difficult to get
a passer while White has four against
three for healthy pawns against free
healthy pawn
so wyd in some way as a yeah it's not
like a material advantage but his pawns
a little bit more valuable let's aim on
the other hand black has got the bishop
pair the interesting moment comes from
champs here got the check now f fire it
was a surprising decision at least for
me it was a surprising decision by grief
shock um that he goes for that locating
set up accepting that check and is
inserted that wide gets this protected
passer and the pawn itself is not yeah
it's not like white is going to do
something with it quickly but long-term
this will still be an issue I mean black
ass I think very very good chances to
hold the position but it feels like a
somewhat tedious affair always just
being able and to defend it's a purely
defensive task um come on I is doing a
good job here he trades off the bishop
and the thing is in this position black
basically has to stay just like that
Queen here blocking their pawn and do
nothing and in the actual game there is
your moment way basically yeah loses
this this kind of setup here is still
only six not this b6 so it's one
particular moment here Queen 31 this is
the thing in this position here instead
of Queen D 1 he um yeah I had to yeah
stay put again do this and shuffle
between those squares and just just do a
sit-in wait strategy I think that white
after this has very little chances of
breaking through he can try but it's a
yeah it's difficult White's bishop it's
not that great and this is the thing in
the game okay this happened of course
and now Queen and bishop
invade with a great effect check and
check it's not better then we have this
note that White's King is perfectly safe
visually seven Queens you six yeah and
that doesn't look good right f5 hangs h5
hangs yeah it's it's a very clear clear
fair now why it is a pawn up and has the
clearly better position with blacks King
being out in the open the only thing
that still various is of course those
ideas at Perpetual's check so what
according to coach a chance check and
right here we have the mysterious moment
of the game yeah you can treat this as a
little exercise and probably will manage
to play better than koala did why to
play and win yeah yeah okay I'll give
you five seconds one two three four five
yeah Queen g6 and black resins right now
that wasn't played quite amazingly this
is just completely over threatening
Bishop g7 and end of game it also covers
his square which is crucial it's very
mysterious why Cara wanna I didn't go
for that he had time time enough him and
it's very logical move here this is the
threat here we have to think about this
cover that that's square so Queen g6 is
supernatural and it tested this idea I
think it's very that's very M comforting
to see that even the such genius players
like Lackawanna they sometimes have
their their moments of complete
blindness here Queen g6 and black can
safely resign I think there was a psalm
112 eat that gooey shock was asked
bye bye Ann Gustafson in the press
conference or in the after game
interview how he could could keep a
poker face while waiting for Queen g6 to
happen and we shook said I just didn't
see it it is typical typical style chat
yeah anyway so why does trying something
different but the thing is that the
White King position is just so bad if
you look at look at this with the
computer the computer will still give
right a very big advantage but
ultimately especially for a human player
this kind of condition is impossible
impossible to check yet to manage and
around here even the engine agrees that
it is a draw it's a gap it's it's a moot
point to find fine trying to find a
improvements here for four wide it's
very difficult for a human anyway and
sometimes even the engines cannot easily
be trusted because they easily get out
of them their horizons the depth that
they can calculate because of why it's
being able to give a ton of checks so
the computer very often will give like
plus one point something because it sees
that white can continue forever with
checks yeah and and kind of drag the
whole thing with the being upon up and
having a nice position all nice and good
but the computer does not see any
substantial progress how to avoid them
at the actual draw at the end that black
is also trying to get with this
perpetual chances like this in this so
at the end um rather take a nap skipped
a couple of news check chance it was a
draw at chent young perpetual tia white
giving the the checks yeah it was a draw
and
of course very lucky at one moment koala
at the screen g6 shot but he didn't he
didn't find it yeah you know the draw um
great in this event is very high but we
shouldn't forget that it was not they
weren't lots of ultra boring short
drawers but they were also in fact quite
a number of games where one side had
excellent winning chances but they
simply spoiled it because of various
things like here this Queen g6 is really
mysterious I think Karen I would play
that in most blitz games even and
somehow he didn't he didn't see it here
okay so let's go for the third burnin
yeah we've got a third one I'm i don't
know i don't i don't understand why
isn't there something slightly different
that she can try again e way check I
mean it's a French defense so bad or the
caro-kann or something like that okay so
we have this now Bishop f4 Bishop e7 and
one of the main lines as far as I know
with Luke age six month yeah like it
activates the rook and that way that
position I think was also discussed in
the world championship matches between
cars and Anton are not we will go a
little bit further up to a particular
position because there is a novel team
can that has oil played before up to
here and this was the game Adams kramnik
from London last year where ultimately
chronic could not completely equalize I
mean okay he tried to do something it
didn't work at the end it was a draw the
thing is that and here Aguirre now comes
up
with a with a novelty yeah and it's not
move 19 in the Berlin so and it's this
move that's quite funny right I have to
see for you would pretty much assume
that that that Bishop has to move but
that's not the case um black rather goes
for the possible check here and guides
it's really a funny move um mdl at the
end decided to take he took a long time
but there is a no great alternative damn
funny enough I mean those nights they
both cannot move and this white supposed
to play if not taking if you move here
black is going check neither three check
and this cannot be a anything grateful
right at all yeah so we decided to take
and i'll give you just recaptures and it
seems that this ends all hopes for a
right advantage black it's now intending
to take here and well you cannot move
any of the nights yeah and then you're
okay wide wide move to the night room
before he gave the check on the six but
you cannot just go somewhere you have to
play this 96 check it seems to be the
only continuation and that makes any
sense if white goes back here mike is
just taking this and and it's better
yeah this got sorry check check and
white is lost he has to do this at 96
and check check 96 back and the funny
thing is that currently this is more
weakness set of strengths Knight f3 be
sure of six activates that and King 27
look aged six yet to get get the rook
back check check check and you guess
that today repeated here for a draw yeah
there's one of those cases where you
feel like ok was that a real game of
chess givi plate complete out of his
preparation up to the end of the game I
guess ok he took 30 minutes to to
recheck and so on and it but it's clear
that up to 94 it was it was all prep
they're here 94 was of course not
devised over the board but was prepared
and he had no problems whatsoever so
this is a this is in a way from a chess
professional point of view a good game
because it's a good preparation you get
it in you get it wrong with black just
not very attractive to watch um yeah
that's how it is with those with those
openings yeah sometimes them if you want
to think about this kind of tournament
format sometimes there was alternative
formats like that knockouts with some
rapid games they are most spectacular to
watch clearly on the other hand it's
it's difficult to just yet scrap all
those longer-term control games because
it's also that the more from pure
quality point of view the the better
chances just that sometimes you feel
like if you have more than fifty percent
of the games are building defenses and
you have the same kind of positions all
the time it just feels a bit stale okay
so let's go for the next game a final
game that we look at in this round are
not to Paolo and the good thing is set
to ball off um is providing some variety
as he plays the night off yeah we got
the night off it's interesting that V
she also has gone back to e4 mostly he
had a very good run in early 2015
playing default where he had fantastic
results it now is back to more of one
year for he's mixing it a little bit of
course here he played the c-4 against
them you can see for against Adams right
yeah in the first round but most of the
time he goes for money for yeah and we
have h 3 again the new main line of the
night off maybe yeah and tomorrow is
sticking to this defense the line that
he already had played against mvl and
lost yeah and I'd no place differently
am entirely differently um Maxine went
for g3 here therefore this fianchetto
orvieto but Bishop g5 now played by Anna
this is of course I'm also quite logical
continuation why does immediately
liquidating that night for his Bishop
and now has the situation that he's got
three pieces that may compete for the d5
square whereas black only has two pieces
to defend it this is a typical scenario
in double sicilian positions where the
d5 square has been has been weakened
like the specially called kalashnikov
there are various lines like that the
ideal scenario is for white to trade the
night and the bishop here those lows for
trade those and then get a knight on d5
oh I'm painting badly getting the night
to d5 that is completely unopposed
that's the the metal strategy let's say
that that white has and keep that in
mind while watching the game 95
black does not want to trade as I said
he doesn't want to trade those 19 23 and
white went for non Castle 297 King be
one Roxy eight or very standard stuff
Luke c5 looking at that crucial d 5
square there should be two or very
normal looking moose I think we don't
have to address them in much detail a
three guarding against possible befalls
and Knight b6 it's an interesting choice
in general as I said black does not want
to trade but it's difficult to play
around that night the whole time the
thing is that if wipe know antiques on
v6 and Queen takes is very difficult now
to rearrange those pieces in a decent
way you don't want to play night d 5 as
after the capture this is replaced by a
pawn and this doesn't really help wide
at all if a pawn gets 35 we had a
similar situation in the mdl to pawn off
game but then um the white player had
castle castle short and then you could
go a 4 and play on the queenside here of
course with long castles this doesn't
make any sense at all black here just
would activate this Bishop somewhere
here or on Bishop g7 was a possible
efore the black Bishop is rather better
than the white Bishop so this was no
good I mean silymarin could have played
that it leads to a very similar and
position in the game b g4 here cakes and
now he took so he could have may be
taken immediately and then go g4
interesting thing is that right took
with the pawn I was originally thinking
that Bishop takes interesting trying to
attempt to black into that structure
which would be really terrible but black
of course it's not doing that he will go
here and then it's not clear that you
have gained from taking with the bishop
so aunt took
the pawn those were traded Bishop g7
yeah and now it's an interesting
interesting moment here in the game in
terms of finding a plan as I said what
why does trying to do is he wants to
trade those bishops if possible if we
can trade e 26 then d 5 will be free for
the night to occupy and ya cannot be
challenged anymore that piece by the
bishop on on g7 if um if you are a
regular viewer of my channel you might
have seen a video that I once made on
the middle game planning and it was
called the eternal night from a game of
fishers against a not so well-known
player Katya where Fisher managed
exactly that established a knight on d5
against the bed bishop and this is what
them unanswered yes now so how do you
trade those bishops that's how ya up to
g5 with the pawn and now angular for
that Bishop g4 of course you can now you
black and go to c4 but that's not so
easy to do this happened now Queen g3
and this way and we it can never go to
c4 but if black plated differently you
also would have to reckon with be three
so any Bishop c4 and the other
circumstance I mean here just the Queen
Hanks so we cannot move at all but then
be three would have been a problem so
here are not gets to get to the scenario
that i mentioned the knight on d5
against that awkward bishop on one of
eight still there's one particular
feature of this position that points
towards and black having better chances
to hold then under other circumstance
and this particular feature is the pawn
on d5 the pollen g5 is a clear weakness
here on white spot it cannot easily be
supported by a four
I mean it can but Beck just takes it and
then you haven't made any kind of gains
that the pond is still let's say a
little bit alone and if Black gets this
Bishop somewhere here which you will
that's the most logical place for anyway
then white has to constantly worry about
that part this position if white spawn
would be back on g4 does just if you
just imagine this pawn let's say rook is
back on g1 and point would be on g4 yeah
then White's position would be
strategically close to winning because
he has all those advantages of the great
night against the offer Bishop and he
can easily play on the Queen so just
imagine we would see how the game
unfolds without white having to worry
about the pawn this may however in it's
not easy at all for white to make
substantial progress and we see that
Islanders all the normal things it
brings his King up and get set that pawn
lever into motion that's how you do it
that'd be 5v5 pawn is good to attack
here black only has a choice between
various evils you can allow right to
take on b5 then the b5 porn is is weak
or you can take they decided to take
check sorry never get this structure I'm
sorry he decided to recapture with the
rook and allow that structure with a and
B porn with a pawn against BNC porn yeah
white now test this before idea and we
see that white gets a passer in this way
if you just imagine this position with
the poem back on g4 and the white rook
free to move you see how great it i sell
wide can invade on the queenside and get
it's just um just a lot better and I'll
I played that very nicely though now
first you did all the normal things and
shuffling that we get to move 40 and now
he simply ditched that Paul yeah just
gave away the G fired upon and this
shows how I mean and white gets very
very good compensate
for the porn his position is so good
that he can allow to give it away the
thing is that without this here why
would have been probably winning at the
point is back on g4 yeah so two part of
took it of course and the question is is
this just a fantastic compensation or is
why term should wide win this it's it's
hard to determine actually there is one
particular moment and this is here where
the engine claims that black is able to
draw with g 4 i'm not entirely sure
about this um because blacks position
still looks yeah very threatened yeah
after Luke a jade I mean black cannot do
that much the engines line is this I can
show you what it gives rupee eight here
check King away and then rooks you want
and I'm inclined to believe that this is
indeed a draw to be honest the thing is
that if why does taking the pawn like
it's starting with checks and it's it's
hard for why to avoid they are because
we cannot check do this because of
Bishop a five I it doesn't lose but it
doesn't doesn't help so what is why it's
supposed to do if he if he goes over
there black is continuing with checks or
you can do this at one point where after
b6 rupee five there's also no winning
chance whatsoever maybe he could have
could have held this with was she fall
maybe I'm not sure looks very very
tricky for black to play the part of
when drew could be eight however chand
after Luke h7 check it seems to be very
very difficult to save here here yeah
and now I mean blacks position is
entirely dominated he cannot move his
bishop for example to any decent square
the only m yeah the only thing that he
could come up with this push the G porn
but it is ultimately ultimately lost now
we get to the
that I described earlier little but yeah
why it's just having orders drums
without having to worry about being a
porn down in this position seems to be
winning four wide there were a couple of
funny general little moments but nothing
too substantial I believe check chair
white can take his time this is the
funny moment check that's not a blunder
the idea is that if white takes it and
Alan could have done that he could have
teak and we can look at this idea was he
for Stan late yep but wyd of course
doesn't have to take after King inform
he still would have had a winning
position point is that Bryn Shander can
give a couple of checks check but it
ends right here with the white knight
being able to to retreat wide winds
pretty easily so a nerd could have taken
the bishop but he preferred to just keep
the position as is and continue like
that and I think ins it should win as
well I mean what's position is just far
too dominating for black to channel it I
know the B porn is decisive check
etymology tried some desperate shattuck
refresh and check check yeah that's it
the e4 pawn is covered and white next
we'll come up here and start picking up
picking up points so a winform anant in
this game so what does that mean for the
overall standings to pal of his clear
last with three losses and two draws
pretty awful tournament one point out of
out of 5 and this loss definitely means
that is entirely out of any run in the
overall standings of the grand chest or
honored with that win goes back to fifty
percent after he had lost to Nakamura in
the previous round and that means that's
all standing
quite funny to polymers on minus three
then half of the field has got fifty
percent and we've got three people with
plus one Giri Nakamura and mvl so funny
standing that means that what we knew
before the event that almost anybody can
win it is still true yeah most of the
field is still in competition for the
for the first place and that net so many
points that it's possible for all of
them all of them to win the event yeah
as I said a huge draw rate I think that
um even though we've got many building
defenses some of them were interesting
but some of them clearly not so I hope
for some other openings it really is
really weird we've got 20 I'm sorry no
we've got dot 25 yeah 25 games in and I
think more of a more than half of them
verbal ins so why not go for something
else there's also i know the Scotch
opening if you want to start with e 45
in the first place okay we've got a rest
day on wednesday the tournament
continues on thursday with round 6 i'll
be online actually for around six for
the icc i'm doing live commentary
together with Grand Master Jo Benjamin
very much looking forward to that and of
course i'll also be covering this round
as recap for my channel will probably be
on early friday and central europe in
time it's not feasible to do it right
after the coverage on on the thursday
because it's it's very it's very it's a
super great thing to do we are those
five hour coverages life for them for
the events but it's after afterwards
you're just feeling like you're
completely dead yeah it's just totally
exhausting ok I hope you enjoyed round
five coverage here thanks for watching